僕には
かれこれ3年以上の付き合いがある5i がいる
あった時から少し変わった人で
たまに怖いと思う時もあったがうん
ぐうっ
何してんのこんなところで
阿部さ遊びましょう
最近の彼がどうしようもなく強く感じてしまうときがある
えええっ
[音楽]
しているのです
からもしろよ
想像方かな
山 a バジルのお前があるためだという
[音楽]
bouvet は仕事で出かける前に行かれと遊んでいた時の話であるロス僕は
はっきりとかねに
ん
インターホンに出るように行ったのだ
[音楽]
ため
またねー
インターホンが
鳴りやまないのだ
おっ
彼はインターホンの前で
スマホを触っていた
[音楽]
坊ん
破ったねー1 hour なんてんじゃない
あってますちょっといいって言ったよねっっ
言って悪かったけどね
星ブーブーんっ
[音楽]
[笑い]
ブーブーうーん
彼とスマブラをしていた時の話てやる感じます
音キスは良い一
あちょっと待っはい電話来たん
ああああああ
ああふらー
彼は待つことなくレスを殴ったらん
その理由を聞くと
頭では分かっていたが体が止まらなかったと言っていた
んね
が分岐おやつに
2層へキロあああああだった
ず
ここ最近お書きになったのはあっ
ヒマさえあれば女性と電話をしていることだ
それも後ろめたいのか分からないか
他の人が来ると隠そうとすると
ポイント拉致次までます not パッティングでしょそれからがっつりやってる
4つ2階ことで相手さで上がったバザーリスがもうな技だったね
もう一つ気になっていることといえば
ずっとスマホを触っていることが多い
それをずっと
右にスワイプしているのさ
あれば
マッチングアプリで片っ端からいいねしていた
後日
たまたまさと歩いていた時だった
俺は見かけてしまった小さければ6袋セット
おっ
マイメロさんですそれじゃあぞ味だしてありがとうございますねっ
よかったことあの特性は消しあるんでチョコ地域を年間
大ケースあれば彼のマッチングアプリの使い方だ
まじめな出会いを探しているようには見えつ
多数の女性取り合い
デイば簿多数の女性としているようだったいっ
ああああああ
彼は最近ハタチの誕生日を迎えた
いよいよ大人としての責任が必要とされた
[音楽]
ええええええ
ono
ああああああ
うわあああああ
これぐらい ni 徒歩ならシャーラー行ったため
ハタチになったらもう酒も飲めるしタバコも整備しギャンブルと思う何度もいろんな
ことでてるけど全部自己責任だかな
昨夜まあいいとしてなたことが本当はお金ないんでしょ
タバコにお金かかるからほんと気をつけろはい
卵の作業はギャンブルをやりません
ame
彼は翌日から酒タバコギャンブルにどっぷりハマっていた
たまにならいいと思う職にも就かない彼が
僕は心配だった
rar
持っていた
はい&増タバコから抜け出し着です
岡谷のタバコを吸い続けていた
2から3そんなまけ山
タバコ記事な
そうですよねー
タバコ止めます
秒前
みんなのより辞める宣言でした箱これでなくだろまずなグラスたうよだれから1本の
タバコを吸い続けていたのだ
me
仕事が終わり
健介が車で帰ろうとしていた時にこの事件は起きた
[音楽]
ああああああ
ていた
ana
豆乳誰です
ん
ルーあああっ気づけたお願いしまーす
開かれが無断で突然人の kreva により
いえば手をふってもらおうとする橋送ればいいはああああっは赤い売るならないのは彼
バッハ
ぜひ人の車に乗り込むのはどうなのだろうか
1やっぱり300本
どうしたちょっと乗ってもらっていいですか
分かった
今ないシーンですか
いわしましたん
彼は本当にナンパをしまくるらしい
よく僕も金にナンパの順番じゃないすか味でよかったいきましょうどっか
aag 行きましょ行きましょ行きましょ行きましょえんちょっとジャケット
酒が分これが
俺くれよねこれがを願うよ俺がね5類お願いこれを破れ
これは家で話をしている時の出来事でやってマジだ沿いで楽しめ
トイレから奇妙な声が聞こえてきたのだん
なんかめっちゃ聞こえる何カッ
で美味しい
それを見てくるが多く予想です
あ
ua ああああっ
[音楽]
なんとこの男
人の家でトイレは全開にしてタップしていたのだ
アナ恥ずかしい
お前さんと入れたじゃあ種類やぶっぱねぇいいねぇいいねぇぞよ
効率が強い名前が占めてるんだよそれえっ
傷与次郎がー
あああああああああ
me
ああああああああ
par ああああ
これは彼の友達から聞いた話である
基本彼は車を持っている友達はしましたね教本遠くまでありがとうございますや言えず
申し訳ないは辞めたからっを楽しかったけどうーん久々だとはめっちゃ楽しかったわ
マジで
坊
でしたた
[音楽]
稚児へ行ってくるからちょっと待って待って言っ声進化マン的な人待ってまたっ
ん
[音楽]
me
そしてに時間が過ぎた
を譲ってい
お前何に時間彼だ友達をでリフィルのために時間が来る場合は設定てほしい
俺じゃなくてよかった俺はっはー
[音楽]
ブーブー5ちょっと後ろサティ
でんすけとはその指導が入るから背景水から帰ってもらいな
はいわかりました分け合い過払いありがとう様が入っ使えそうです
[音楽]
[拍手]
高を受けましたすみません
いい頑張りたい感じそうそうでしょ
数が下げておりません
もちろん彼がこのお金を動画のために使うと思っていた
この時は
後日僕たちが近所な寄付を立て後は見かけてしまったら
ああああああ
[音楽]
あったねそっとね
あるいは依存なといいねぇ
あれ形成3万以下しなかったっけコスト
[音楽]
あれお金が入ってなかった格好になっていってますよ同社はお金がないと言っていた彼
が今日って借りたわかるんだよ
女性に起こっていたのとかいい
話し合いましてんだ
ん
[音楽]
はまっ子画面がありますがそして彼は日にちを決めてお金を返すと言っていただく
その日にお金が返ってくることはなかったんです
[音楽]